- Hi, I'm Catherine McCord
and today on Pro Tips from Pro Chefs,
I'm gonna be showing you road trip snacks
that are gonna save you as
you head on your destination
and make sure that your bellies are full.
- Something we already know,
America loves road trips.
- Oh, can we talk about road trip snacks?
(lively music)
- One of our favorite travel recipes
are these cucumber stackers.
They're also perfect
if you are gluten free,
'cause there's no bread in them.
So you can take a cucumber,
Persian or English
cucumber, whatever you like.
You can keep the skin on or skin off.
I like the skin on,
especially with the Persians,
because they are much thinner
than an English cucumber.
And you wanna cut them
about a half an inch
and just remember, this is your bread.
Not exactly the bread
that you might be used to
but it gives a little bit of crunch
and you get a vegetable in there too.
Then we're gonna take some
cheese and some turkey.
So you can put 'em side by
side, on top of each other,
whatever you like.
Now is the fun part, cookie cutters.
They are not just for Christmas.
I use them all year round in
different kinds of shapes.
These are kind of flowers
and clouds and stars,
but again, use what you've got.
So I just take them like this, super fun.
You can get your kids involved if you want
'cause it's a really fun one.
All right, and again,
like different shapes.
And when they're eating
them, you can have them say,
like, what kind of shape
do you think is in there?
Because on a long trip,
you wanna keep everyone
as entertained as possible.
Okay, so you're gonna put a cucumber
and put your star on top
and then you can just place
them right on top like that.
And you can use other
kinds of deli meat too.
You could use ham, pastrami, roast beef.
Same thing goes with the cheese.
I like to use cheddar
but you could also use
mozzarella, Colby, muenster,
Swiss, anything you enjoy.
All right, so I've got my turkey
and I'm just gonna put
my cheese right on top.
All you do is put the
cucumber right on top
and that is a cucumber stacker,
only three ingredients.
The perfect bite size treat
to get a vegetable in there
and protein as you're traveling
and make sure that no one
gets hangry on your road trip.
And don't forget, if you
have scraps like this,
feel free to throw 'em in a sandwich now
and keep your cucumber stackers for later.
Peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches are totally yesterday.
I am talking about peanut
butter and jelly pop tarts.
These are homemade,
only three ingredients.
You need pie crust, that
you can make yourself
or you can buy prepared
in the refrigerator
section of your grocery.
And then I just fill them,
these little squares about
two inches by three inches,
with a teaspoon of peanut
butter, a teaspoon of jelly.
You bake them up in a 400 degree oven
until they're nice and golden like this.
Now, the fun part though,
comes with the glaze.
So I like to put one on a surface
and then I've got a little
bit of powdered sugar here.
After all, you're on a road trip
and it's all about making
it as fun as possible.
So in the powdered sugar, I
like to put some food color
and then you're gonna
just add in a little milk.
Now you wanna do this
a little bit at a time
because we're just trying to
make a really beautiful glaze.
And ask your kids what color they want.
Blue, green, yellow,
they can play with their primary colors.
All right, just slowly stir, stir, stir,
adding just a little bit
of that milk at a time
'cause you wanna make sure that
your glaze is thick enough.
You don't want it to be too runny.
All right, so stir it.
Ooh yes, that's what we're talking about.
Look at that pretty, pretty color.
And you just want it like
that kind of a consistency.
Just thick enough, but
spreadable at the same time.
And then we're just gonna
put a little of that glaze.
Let it drip, drip, drip so
it doesn't make a big mess
and then we're just gonna
spread it right on it.
Like to use a spoon
'cause it makes it easier
just to spread it all around.
And just that extra
bit of sweetness on top
makes it fun to look at,
but also to enjoy tasting.
And then, just to really up the ante,
I like to put some sprinkles on top.
Just a few to give it a little pop.
Look how cute those are.
They're like the perfect summertime treat.
(upbeat music)
At any given time, I have four
boxes of cereal in my pantry
with just about this much leftover.
So these cereal bars are the perfect use
for that kind of leftover cereal.
I dump them in, I add
a ton of peanut butter
or any kind of nut or
seed butter that you like,
a little bit of coconut oil,
which is the greatest tip
kind of keeping them together,
and then some oats so that you get
that whole grain goodness.
I put everything into this
nine by nine inch pan.
Always line your pans with
parchment paper, just like this.
That way, they pull right out.
It makes clean up and
cutting them a breeze.
So just take that parchment
and then take a serrated knife
and we're just gonna cut them like this.
Another great tip is if you feel like
you need to head out on your road trip
and you wanna make these really fast,
just put 'em in the freezer
'cause they'll set up really quick.
And then we can just turn,
turn, turn and cut them.
Ugh, look at that.
Not only are they absolutely
delicious, but look at that.
Any kind of cereal you like is gonna work
for these on the go bars.
I don't know many kids
who don't love cereal
but who wants to take milk with
their cereal on a road trip?
These cereal bars are a ton more fun,
have a lot of protein
in them, and no mess.
Last but definitely not least
is my super healthy granola.
I have a batch of this
with me at all times.
Why? Because it is like hearty,
you can put it in parfaits.
I'm gonna tell you my tip
for getting these huge chunks
that look more like granola
bars than they do granola.
So after you add in all
of your ingredients,
you're gonna allow it to spread out,
bake it in a 250 degree oven
for about an hour and 45 minutes,
take it out and totally let it cool
because that cooling
process allows it to get
nice and crispy, stick together.
So when it comes out of the
oven, it's in these huge chunks,
you can break into smaller
pieces, put in a bag.
And that, for me, is the
best on the go snack.
The reason I love this
granola and making it,
it's so much better than store bought.
You can control the ingredients in here.
You get a lot more bang for your buck
and it's not too sweet.
There's no refined sweeteners in it.
So it's just that perfect
kiss in every single bite.
For more pro tips, head to
TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com/protips.
And if you make any of
these recipes on the go,
tag me @Weelicious, #DrewBarrymoreShow.
Thanks for having me,
Drew, this was so much fun.
(jazzy big band music)